go to that one quick
boom
and there it is
all right y'all welcome to
a live bonus episode
[Music]
oh yeah we live
oh yeah on this matic productions
[__] gregory griffin is here
yeah what again
[Music]
all you
everybody tell your friends
and we doing it live
trying to stay alive oh yeah
here we go here we go with this
again this is a bonus episode
all right we're back all right hello
everybody welcome to roofing with
griffin bonus episode bonus
episode 144 bonus episode 144
uh make sure you check out this week's
riffing with griffin the main episode
with spencer sutherland
you know some of y'all are not really
looking at that episode and i don't know
why the dude's
like a really fantastic it's a very
interesting guy
singer and he's really about to blow up
so you know you really should look at
him and see
what's going on with that so make sure
you check that out
and um i got some dates coming up real
soon in the california area so
if you are in cali um
and this is live i can see the live chat
right there so welcome everybody that's
in here live this is just for youtube
bonus episode this week so what's up
everybody out there
mar loka being a member of the youtube
family thank you
i see all of you robin damon trey all
you guys
thanks for being here riffing with
griffin live um
so i got some dates coming up so i'm
gonna be at the brea improv so make sure
you tell your friends braya improv if
you're in the
uh la area brea the 19th i don't have
the link
on my website but it is on my instagram
but i'm gonna fix that up later today
later before i go to bed i'm gonna make
sure that the link is up
on and then if you were coming to see me
in chicago at the den theater
i have to move that date because adam
devine's wedding is
actually on the date of that so i'm
going to his wedding and it's like a
destination wedding so it's like a whole
vacation thing for me and rachel
so make sure so again i'm going to be at
the brea improv i believe
on the 19th yes it is on the 19th and
we'll be at the bray
improv it's a thursday august 19th
all right so august 19th we'll be at the
brady improv and on the 20th i'm going
to be
out in san diego one in escondido
not really san diego it's in san diego
escondido at the grand comedy theater
grand comedy club i'm doing that one
again so make sure you check out those
dates
um and thanks for you know again thanks
for being here
but make sure that you know for all you
la people the brand improv
is a huge place i'm just doing one night
so i really like to get as many people
in there as possible so make sure you
get your tickets
if you go to my instagram there's a
ticket link there on my instagram
for the um the brand improv so
there's that so yeah so and again please
watch episode 144
of with spencer sutherland all right so
we're there so we're live i'm live and
wiggy's here
wigs where you at there's wigs is back
uh on the screen here so we just you
know i've had him come over we're doing
a
this little bonus episode so i got some
stuff wigs that i
uh already was going to talk about but i
know you have a bunch of stuff so
whatever the bunch of stuff you can get
all that stuff ready too but
yeah so um a couple things so i saw the
quiet place too
so i want to talk about that recap the
nba
uh talk about that and i want to tell
you all about my
engagement i did it i asked you know i
gave rachel the ring
and we did that and
what else um yeah and then we'll just
you know
then i'll take i might even take some
questions from the chat
i wanted to do real world advice i had
it on my twitter let me see if i got
some tweets
about it if not if you guys have some we
could do some live
real world advice from a grown ass man
chat
um you know it is what it is
guys but anyways you know this is this
is we're doing this live
i am coming to the dc area if you go to
my website i am coming to the dc
area i'm going to be at the arlington
draft house and i believe that's in the
dc area
so make sure you uh check that out i
gotta i got dates if you want to see me
you gotta come check those dates out
so all right first like the big thing is
let's talk about the engagement so
i had this ring i got the ring rachel
knew what kind of ring she wanted so i
got her the ring that she wanted all
right
i knew you know it's tiffany i got her
tiffany's ring
she wanted a tiffany's ring i could have
gone someplace else i could have made it
you know i could have done it cheaper
everybody was like oh i got a diamond
guy
but i knew my chick wanted to tiffany's
box with a tiffany's ring she wanted to
go into tiffany she wants to be able to
go in there and they clean it in there
and
talk to the people and be like oh get
her ring resized
at tiffany she wanted the tiffany's
experience and and you know what it's
her thing right so she should get that
so but i'd had it for so long and i
didn't know how to do it so i was gonna
do it like
one day i was at the comedy store and
she came with her friends and i thought
this would be a perfect time i'm on the
main room stage and i'll just be like
okay everybody and then like do that
but like rachel don't like that kind of
attention and she gets social anxiety
and she don't like a lot of crowds
so i knew that would have been a good
idea she didn't want food no you know
you know that kind of thing
and and it just was like you know you
try to come up with these grand gestures
but
so we've been talking about so long so i
just was in our it was just here we were
here
i had this nice balcony off our bedroom
you know and then she went and then
every time she'd be like don't do it yet
because i didn't get my nails done
don't do it yet because i want to get
where a certain thing you know so
she we finally i was like i'm doing it
so she put on this beautiful dress you
know and i had her go out on the balcony
i had some music on my my beats uh my
my pill a beats pill i i started i
played
some really nice music and then i didn't
i didn't she didn't know i was gonna do
this i put on a jacket
and then i went out i had her sit down
on this we have a beautiful chair out
there and i got on one knee and it was
like a beautiful night and you know and
i said what i needed to say
we both started crying i put the ring on
her finger
and then you know it was that was that
and then like the next day she went to
tiffany's to get it resized you know
and then she got it back a week later
and then every time when she got it back
a week later she was like well you have
to propose again
so you've just been proposing every
morning yeah so that was different
that's a new thing that started she saw
this on something
and then she was like so every she
doesn't sleep with the ring because it's
sharp you know what i mean it's like a
[__] diamond ring so she like takes
it off puts it in a box
so in the morning she goes hey you know
she saw this on a tick tock or something
so then
every morning now when i wake up i she
gives me the ring and she wants me to
propose
and she's so like sensitive like that
and very like loving and so she just
she it fills her with joy every time i
can see it on her face and she just
smiles and she cries sometimes
and so i just do that every single
morning now as
a thing you know we'll see how long that
lasts right
but for now that's the lovely thing that
uh that we do and and it's great you
know
so that's going on um that happened
so another thing that i did i wasn't
even going to talk about this but i want
to talk about it so i have somebody
really close to me he's like a brother
he's like he's a brother to me all right
i always call him my brother but he's
not my real brother but he's my brother
all right but he's got some issues you
know what i mean he's in a treatment
center
uh you know he's a freaking addict okay
and he's working on it you know and it's
been a long struggle a 10-year struggle
it didn't start like that but anyways
it's tough
so the other day though this program
that he's in
they had this family counseling you know
and he said okay it's a zoom call you
come on on wednesdays now
at first i thought he was going to be
there and then it was going to be like
you know
you talk with the counselor and a bunch
of you you're all talking and
everybody's just talking about this
you know but it wasn't it was just the
family members you know
so i was a little taken aback by that i
was like oh [__] what you know
but at the same time it was like because
it's very much like al-anon
you know i don't know if you guys know
what alanon is but you know it's like
support for people uh loved ones of
addicts
and this was very similar to that but
also it had
like it was like a lesson and they were
talking about boundaries
you know and and it was like it but it
was so
interesting and moving to see like all
these people dealing with stuff on a
different level it was like all these
parents and you know
you know it was just like oh man it was
a lot you know it was very i was
i it was a lot you know what i mean
um i'm not in the chat guys but wiggy's
behind the keyboards i mean i could get
on chat if i go on my phone right here
and i could like type
stuff but i'm right here i could just
say i could see what you're saying so
i'll just say whatever you're saying but
hello people i see you in the chat it's
live we're live right now
you know but anyways so i did this
family thing
and it was very like i don't i do
recommend it
if you're if you're dealing with a loved
one who's an addict
alcoholic drugs addiction any kind of
addiction
you know it could be gambling it could
be anything like that i do highly
recommend that you
uh go to like an allen on type program
or you know
if they have zoom ones they have live
ones and you really to just just feel
like you're not alone
because you know you have so much guilt
and like
the boundaries that you know you have to
put up
uh to feel like you're doing the right
thing i mean it's a lot
man it's it's it was it was a lot so it
was it was a lot for me to process and
deal with but i got a lot of useful
information
about you know boundaries and you know i
think that that is something that
you know we can all like work on
you know what i mean we can all work on
that so
as i'm looking at the chat um hello chad
hello
my my cousin is in chat alyssa alyssa
perez is my cousin
my og cousin one of my fave my favorites
you know i only have like two cousins
that i consider my favorite and she's
one of them
she's at the top i got she's here now so
i gotta say at the top of the list
so uh everybody say hi to my cousin
alyssa
um so anyways what else was i gonna yip
yap about
oh so here's some like bitching with
griffin uh stuff and we gotta we gotta
get some logos for this stuff
wigs we gotta be like someone i'm
bitching about something that's like
bitching with griffin you know maybe i
should use the
mic for this part bitchin with
griffin so
anyways i went to century city mall okay
so i what i love about the century city
mall is got smart parking
and this is so petty by the way what i'm
about to talk about this patty is
[__] okay i'm just gonna be honest with
you it's petty
all right so i
um all right so you pull it they have
smart parking so you don't have to get a
ticket
they recognize your license plate so
when you pull in
you know a region license plate and a
little screen says
welcome eric you know it's like welcome
eric and you're like oh cool
thank you you feel good welcome eric you
drive in
now when you leave they reading your
license plate
and they're trying to figure out how
long you've been here and how much money
you owe
then they just take the money and they
just say bye
and i was like hey [__] you need to
give me like a
buy eric thank you for paying or
something like that
i just thought that was so rude it's
like it's
it's like when people get your money
then they done you know what i mean
i should tweet that i'm live right now
people you know people get your money
and then they're like all right we got
your money so we're not gonna
deal with it oh thank you cc moon you
know you know what i'm supposed to do is
i'm supposed to do my
i'm wait wait wait you uh when you super
chat you will get
your own personal rap but let me just go
on here real quick
and uh tweet about the episode so
you know what i mean people yeah so i
just was like i know that seems petty
but it's like yo can we get
um you know what i mean can i get some
can i get some personal love here uh
freaking
um westfield mall
parking say goodbye to me you know what
i mean all right
i'm tweeting that we're live right now
wait hold yeah this is this is so live
that i'm doing this live
live now
all right and then i should probably go
on instagram let me make an instagram
story this is how we do this guys we do
stuff
we do we do stuff live in full effect
well i have it on the fly
live and on the fly what have you been
doing wigs tell me about tell
while i'm doing this tell us a little
bit about what's going on go to the big
go to big wig
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's a little crop bit of a
cropping error but
cause you keep moving the dm camera okay
so what's what's going on with big wigs
[__] not too much i don't know just i
don't know
what i shot uh oh tell us what yeah tell
us what you're shooting then i want to
know if you want to talk about your
personal situation
no not really but uh
[Laughter]
uh wigs is dealing with stuff
no but um i don't know just you know
more
brand stuff just girls and like athletic
clothes
oh really she's been editing that stuff
yeah yeah actually wait
i could yeah show us we is there
anything you can show us
yeah i mean it's pretty basic it's just
like stuff for
um for instagram
yeah wigs is like he's always doing
stuff
behind the scenes you don't even know
it's just for
uh like this brand's instagram so that's
you know
all right there we go all right guys i
got that up on my story pretty boring
stuff but
oh that's good stuff what are you
talking about
it has like an 80s beat on it oh you
have to turn the
there you go it's a little loud yeah
you can turn the volume controls right
there see for the thing there
on no on the uh the machine on the uh
the switcher you see the volume one
right there
it does look very 80s and you filmed
this and you edit it you do all that
stuff yourself
yeah yeah so it's just like she this
girl is like collabing with this brand
and it's her line of clothes all right
well there's wiggy doing his wiggy stuff
yeah that's wiggy stuff getting wiggy
with it yeah
all right but anyways uh thanks to uh
who gave us
who who gave us some super chats so we
got some cece moon we got see
we got cc moon with some super chats and
we got mar
loka mar loka with some super chats okay
let me go to my let me go let me get one
of my old school beats
yeah there we go this is a money beat
that's it yeah san jose
with 10 super chat
everybody else is whack and then we got
cece moon
doing the doom and then
hey thanks for the 1.99
[Music]
we live on youtube everybody's in the
mood
okay that's all they get that was good
it was only 1.99
[Laughter]
so then what then we got to do marlowka
i i had i oh
so we got and who else san jose shark
and
i got strong i said san jose again yeah
we got oh there's only
another 99 cents from cc moon 99
okay she got that
and we're barbara loka
[Music]
all right so there we go so you get the
super chat
[Laughter]
those are fire that's how we do that new
beats are fire
yeah i got no these are actually some
old beats i got obs i got some new beats
my dudes uh this guy
kyle quiz mundo kyle quiz mundo shout
out to him he makes a lot of great beats
for me
so i'm trying to do a song so i'm trying
to do a song called dad [__]
because you know when dads do stuff like
when dads rap and do stuff they're not
supposed to do like tick tock that's
that's you know so it's gonna be on this
beat right here
oh and as a matter of fact we got some
super chats
[Music]
and we do it again with that that [__]
everybody know it's lit i ain't never
gonna quit
cause every grip is the [__]
[Music]
that's fine all right so anyways what
else is up um
you have some stuff too right but we'll
get to that let me just get a couple
things
so let me recap let me recap so the the
nba
finals is you know i love talking about
the nba so you know the
uh the the bucks won the championship
right so bucks won the championship
but i was thinking about something you
know the nba has been weird so i know
this particular past season there was a
lot of
um injuries the most injuries we've had
in a very long time
in the nba you know playoffs i mean
kawhi leonard was hurt lebron james got
hurt uh
anthony davis was hurt kyrie irving got
hurt
uh donovan mitchell got hurt uh you know
kawhi leonard
i mean it was just like non-stop people
got hurt
and so we ended up with the sons and the
bucks in the championship
now the bucks were getting their ass
handed to them by the nets
and then kyrie irving got hurt and so
they won in seven games okay
but like i don't think they even stood a
chance with with just kevin durant and
kyrie irving they didn't stand a chance
right
so then you have the suns too i don't
think the suns would have beat the
lakers if if lebron and kd
and uh anthony davis were 100 percent
you know it just
it just was and i don't think they would
have beat the clippers even if they
would
would have got past the lakers i don't
think they would have beat the clippers
would have
with a healthy kawhi leonard so i'm not
saying you put an
asterisk by the champion by the by the
thing but it's just one of those things
where you go
man this was a weird championship and
then i started to think
guys the last five years
every single champion you could say
is is is kind of it's iffy so let's go
back
so you got this year we went through all
the things so the bucks they got their
championship
but it was some some nonsense behind all
the injuries right
last year the lakers won but that was in
the bubble after the
see they had time to rest and all that
this year they didn't have time to rest
the injuries caught up to him and look
what happened they they didn't make the
championship they didn't even make the
second round right
so that's what uh you know you could
look back at last year's championship
with the lakers that one's iffy
not asterix but we'll just talk about
the iffy championships
okay after that let's go the year before
toronto
um clay thompson gets hurt kevin durant
gets hurt
toronto wins a championship we know they
wouldn't have beat golden state with a
full team
so that's an iffy championship then you
go but that now the last two years
of golden state
last two years ago in the state those
are iffy championships to me
the iffy because it was a super team
like a super duper duper team
we're talking about golden state was
this they won 73 games and then they
added kevin durant okay so that
it just was like that those two
ridiculous then the year before that
cleveland won cleveland won draymond
green
gets suspended they were up 3-1 at the
time
cleveland comes back and win wins
then before that you had
golden state won kevin love
and kyrie irving got hurt lebron james
took him to six games
so once again the last
five championships were just
iffy in my opinion iffy so
next year so now i'm hearing that
russell westbrook is
probably going to be a los angeles laker
and that is
crazy that'll be crazy but i love it let
me tell you why i love it
i want to see lebron russell westbrook
and anthony davis
versus kevin durant kyrie irving and um
what's his name james harden next verse
lakers championship
it's the only championship we want to
see it's the only two teams you want to
see in a championship
that will make it just awesome okay
because for a lot of reasons reason
number one
they've swapped teammates from the first
time they faced each other
you know they sort of you know like it's
like
lebron won a championship with kyrie uh
and then kevin durant didn't win a
championship with russell westbrook
okay so if lebron wins with russell
westbrook
we know it was kd's fault you know what
i mean
if kd wins with kyrie irving then we go
oh kyrie gets a little bit more
appreciation for the cleveland
championship
right so it's like it's so much to
unpack right there that just and then
the rivalry you know how kevin durant
and russell bessemer was going at each
other that rival will
be dope and then lebron you know trying
to still be the best player at 30
you know seven years old and you know
you know what i mean so
it's gonna be great i just love uh i
can't wait for next season and you know
the draft was on tonight i didn't really
look at all the stuff that was going on
but
it is what it is with that so i got that
all right last thing i'm gonna talk
about and then wiggs has got a bunch of
stuff that he wants to do
is the i saw the why are you laughing i
only have a couple things
oh okay well you sent me a whole list on
your your thing
this is just a bonus episode anyway we
don't have to go along with this we
don't got to go along it's just a bonus
episode
uh i'm a huge clipper fan guys i see you
in the chat david day i'm a huge clipper
fan
but i'm also a i'm a bigger basketball
fan all right and i
i just would like to see nets lakers in
the championship if russell westbrook is
on the lakers
but but lakers clippers that series is
gonna be awesome too
i don't know where if if if chris
paul is coming back to the suns i'd like
to see that because i think that they're
better you know i think they were good
um you know what i mean you see that you
see that noah guy right there
that said that you know give him a
timeout
you just yeah you just click his name
and just give him a timeout
put user in timeout boom live
[Laughter]
i timeout like those kind of stupid
questions um
anyways so we're gonna do that all right
so let's talk about this movie quiet
place
so i saw quiet place two and man
i don't know if you guys saw the first
quiet place do you see first quiet place
wiggy
i never did actually oh you got to watch
the quiet place it's really good okay
the first quad place was good
i mean the the the um the the the plot
of the first movie is
it picks up where there's an alien
invasion
and these aliens they're they have super
hearing
you know they can't see but they
sense things with their hearing that's
what the first one's about yes
and so it picks up where i didn't know
aliens were involved yeah so it picks up
like it picks up like
maybe a year in okay you know and then
like so this is how people are living
they have to be quiet
you know that's the whole point that's
why it's called the quiet place so
they're like they're they're tiptoeing
around all the time
anytime they make noise the monsters
come and they're scary
they're scary-ass monsters man and so in
the first movie one of the kids dies
you know because and one of the girls is
deaf and so you know it's in john
what is his name karinsky if i believe
that's his name yeah yeah
maybe don't show too much of it because
they'll they'll being us
yeah what are you doing yeah they did i
just wanted to see the monsters attack
um john because from the office he wrote
and directed it right
and he did a fabulous job i mean i've
heard yeah i've heard they're really
really good yeah they're really good so
the first one was really good and emily
blunt is great
okay so it's really great it's great
it's really like
like like when the d when the the girl
that's deaf
when she's on the screen and there and
to show you that like you feel what she
feels
it's completely silent like there's no
sound no music no nothing
and it's really terrifying it really
really adds something to it so
so they had that this was the first one
guys there's no if you haven't seen the
first one go [__] yourself you know what
i mean
like i'm not spoiler alert like [__] off
this is the first one
spoiler alert now for the second one
spoiler i'm not even gonna talk
the second one is great and the second
one kind of picks up it first of all it
goes
back it goes back to the beginning which
is great
and then it just tells a new story about
his about his kids and
and what because he because something
you know you just find out that
like a continued story and i believe
they're even gonna do a part three
because the universe is so rich
but i do highly recommend this i mean
there's
like the kids in this movie are so good
you know because it's just like
terrifying like you know this is like
great because it's like what you're
seeing right there was like
oh see the monster right there oh my god
it's just it's really scary yeah i want
to watch it have you seen uh
chronicle chronicle yeah that's old
school is that one of those
lost footage movies no no no well no but
it's it's about it's set in seattle
that's why i was it new no it was i
think it came out in 2012.
but no you should watch it if you
haven't seen it it kind of reminds me i
think there's like weird creatures like
that oh okay
well maybe we'll have i'll have to check
that out and if it's not good wiggy's
getting a demerit
gets a demerit say in the who everybody
uh respond in the chat if you've seen it
if you like it or not yeah who's seen
chronicle from 2012 it's pretty good all
right
um but yeah but i would say the quiet
place is
pretty good quite played quiet place two
is worth watching
now i haven't seen any of these new
movies where you have to go to the
theater and see the movies i
i haven't yeah i haven't done that yet i
haven't done so i really want to do that
because there's a couple of them i want
to see like i want to see old
um i want you know because let's see if
m night shyamalan got his [__] together
did you ever you never saw that um
i mean this isn't in the theater well
they might have put this in the theater
too but the the nobody with uh no i
haven't seen
i haven't seen nobody yet i believe that
i believe that might be on amazon prime
that's another one
yeah i torented it i do want to check
that one out yeah
uh oh so somebody says chronicle is dope
and underrated right
so thank you you know what you knew it
wait you
you you who no no do not
look a dumbass name he did that he he
commented just so that
he would try and say his name okay see
ed right there
oh [__] give ed a timeout
ed banger yeah yeah yeah
banger you're out of here it's one of my
eric griffin gaming guys but he's
getting the time out for being a little
[__]
time out buddy you're out of here
time out for you ed what else you've
been watching though um i saw
sweet tooth on netflix which i thought
was also very good
sweet tooth is really good um it's about
like
one of these post-apocalyptic you know
the world
it's got some kind of disease and then
like uh the kids are mutated into
half animals so like they got horns and
or they're like half man
half human half lizard half human half
rabbit that kind of thing
and so and it's just about how there is
a group of people that are trying to
like
wipe those people out and then there's
other groups of people who are like no
we you know these are the people that
are going to thrive in this but it's a
really sweet story and
and and the kid that's playing sweet
tooth is really good
so there he is right there he's like
half he's got antlers
yeah and it's it's crazy yeah it's
really good
but it's actually really touching the
show it's like a 10-8 episode eight or
nine episodes so i watched the whole
thing
i don't personally like that you can
like binge watch on netflix i like the
once a week thing
because then you have to wait you can
like anticipate you can talk about it i
can't stand it
yeah but that's why they should do it
because you know you'll be like
but that feeling you get of waiting
that's great
but you're also more invested in it you
don't because then you can like get to
know the characters and like
when you watch a whole series in like
you know five days
man you're you're done with it you don't
even remember things because you've
moved on to the next so oh sure
i don't know so about um this
have you heard about this would which
one which one uh the white lotus
everybody is talking about white lotus
this is a show right
yeah it's pretty good it's a show on
what uh hbo
oh hbo max okay i am going to watch
white lotus because everybody keeps
talking there's a lot of people
in it yeah a lot of pretty decently big
actors
yeah i'ma check out white lotus because
everybody keeps talking about that yeah
it's pretty good it's like it's like one
of those
shows where you're like like you're the
the whole show is on edge and it's just
kind of weird and you're
and like nothing is really like
happening
but you're like it's just every it's a
bunch of little like
you're just on edge the whole time
you're like what is you know um
the lady who plays stiffler's mom in
american pie yeah
yeah yeah she's in it and she has like
she but she plays like a super serious
role
and she's good she i think she's a great
actor but um
yeah she plays but she's just like kind
of off like not she doesn't do anything
problematic but you're kind of just like
waiting
the whole time for her to like god i
hate the word problematic
but like you know what i mean like she
didn't she wasn't
there was no she wasn't causing any
issues well my cousin is saying she
watched the first episode and said it's
a lot going on
but i can't trust alyssa cause she will
she will start watching the show
and then stop watching it and then i
can't talk to her about the show anymore
because she don't watch it like i can't
stand
that like if you have a family member or
somebody that like
you like if you if you and i wiggy or
like say we're watching the show
and you both we both like so then every
week we're like i'm like oh wait then
you go oh i haven't seen it yet don't
tell me about the you know i can't stand
that [__]
and then i'm like three four episodes
ahead and then it's like now we can't
even share that experience anymore
because yeah i don't i don't care you
can always spoil
spoil [__] for me but uh it has your boy
in it from uh
i'm dying up here uh oh yeah
yeah jake yeah oh yeah i'm about to hit
him up yeah he's super good he killed it
oh maybe i have to get him on maybe i
will have to zoom him on to the podcast
i think he's in i don't think he's in
l.a yeah that'll be um all right here's
something i
here's i just remember something else i
wanted to yip yap about real quick
yeah okay so the the the comedy store
is going to all vaccinated shows okay
because the this delta variant and all
this you know about the virus and all
that stuff that's going on and everybody
you know the people that are
unvaccinated
and listen i ain't going to get wild out
there yeah i'm not going to get into a
whole thing about
vax or not but i will say this if you're
not vaccinated
please make an informed choice about why
you're not being
vaccinated so like i really want to do a
thing where i look up
i want to know what's in the vaccine so
because because
people are saying like if you you don't
want to take it why
you know you know you know why we don't
have polio anymore
vaccines measles you know
vaccines i mean there's so many things
that you know like
the evidence that these things are
useful and helpful there's enough
information out there so if you're not
going to take it i respect your choice
but make sure you're doing it because
you know not just because it's like
because the evidence is showing that
this is helping
so you know make sure you just make an
informed choice
so now the economy stores decided
because they're going to go to all
vaccinated shows so
there's this whole stupid twit twitch i
mean twitter thread
you know i hate that i'm a part of it i
had to mute it because i don't want to
see this [__]
because there are some people that are
really upset about it's like oh you got
vaccinated you know it's like why are
you doing that
but here's the thing when you're at a
show people aren't really wearing new
masks because they're drinking
so you got people drinking it people are
laughing and they're projecting and you
know it's like
at a show man it's like you know it's a
super spreader event could happen
because people are just laughing out
loud and they're sitting close together
and that's just it is what it is we've
been you know
and so if you're if you're the a place
you and you're worried about liability
so here's somebody coming in who's not
vaccinated we you know
we don't know what's going on with this
delta variant and there's new variants
that are coming out
you know you don't want somebody at your
business who's dope
who's decided you know they don't want
to you know
be they don't want to do this then
you're like all right well then don't
come here
because we're trying to make sure that
we're not getting people sick or people
aren't getting sick on our premises
because then you can start doing the
contact racing and then it's like oh man
people
all it takes is like some news outlet to
be like seven people
got sick at the comedy store seven
people got sick at such and such club
and then all of a sudden it's the whole
thing
you know and it can still happen i mean
you know what a crazy i know
more people right now i know personally
more people personally who have gotten
covet who are vaccinated
then i know who when there was no
vaccine
that got coveted i know more people now
that have gotten covet you know you know
and it's so bizarre they've gotten
covert with the vaccine
i know more of those people and the
thing is but the thing about it is
they're it's not serious uh you know
knock on wood my girl my fiance's
grandmother
got coveted and she's like 78 79 years
old man
so it was like thank god she was
vaccinated because
that's the kind of thing that it was
wiping out old folks in uh
florida you know because she's in
florida so anyways
yeah my roommate uh his he works at a
weed store and
there's like it's like half their staff
is out with kovid right now it's like
insane well they probably those weed
people just probably forgot to take it
they forgot they don't even remember if
they're vaccinated or not
no i think they're all vexed right it's
crazy oh but they're okay though right
yeah they're they're okay they're just i
mean they just have to they can't work
yeah oh wow and then my roommate felt
shitty today when got a test
he's negative but oh man and you and
you're good but you're vaccinating i
remember you
we're all back yeah yeah cause you were
like you were like a little [__] when
you got the vaccine
that [__] knocked me out for a day
he was like he had his cat like oh my
god
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was it was gnarly that that day i
felt like i was just like on a
xanax like yeah you know it didn't
affect me like that at all i took
two shots i was just super achy and then
i felt like
maybe like like kind of like a xanax
just like
out of it oh but but anyways guys
the point is i i i i got it i mean you
know i got vaccinated i think you you
know don't what i'm saying is if you
don't want to get vaccinated
don't be mad that businesses are like
yeah well we will
we don't want you here if you don't want
to give accident that's their right
there's a private business this is a
list of ingredients but
if i put it on the screen are we going
to get like no i don't
kicked off youtube oh i hope not right
what
what what this is the facts right yeah
what's in there
uh mrna listen we're not scientists so
it's delicious
it doesn't even matter but my point is
this though
like do you know what's in nyquil like
what's your go what's your go-to
uh cough medicine you know ask yourself
that
what's your go-to like when you get a
cold what's your go-to medicine
do you know what's in it you know do you
do you still take it and why do you take
it
like why are you taking nyquil why are
you taking tylenol cold and flu
why are you taking you know robitussin
why are you like why are you taking
these things do you know what's in them
you know but you take them you know what
i mean so it's like you know i
i just we need to like so it's like i do
want to delve into like what's in it and
be like i wonder what these things are
be great to have a doctor or somebody be
like hey what's this what does it do
what is this what is this
because then maybe we could be like oh
this isn't so bad but they're making it
out like it's like
some kind of thing that's going to make
your balls fall off or something like
that
you know i i don't know what the
anti-vaxxer
stance is i'm not talking [__] about it
i'm just you know i would actually like
to know like
why don't you want to take it like if
you're not informed then you're just
kind of like well then
you know this this just sounds crazy if
you just go yeah i don't want to take it
you know you know what i mean yeah and
um
no it doesn't i'm not comparing you know
like the the things i'm not comparing
that you know i'm just saying
we often take things that we don't know
what they
are you know we often do that we often
we don't know the ingredients of
everything that we put in our bodies
and we still do it and we do it because
we trust whatever
the science is behind it is what i'm
trying that's the point i'm trying to
make
you know what i mean so it's like i'm
not saying that taking cold medicine
and then getting a a you know a shot
that takes like
a sec like literally the needle's not
even that big
it's not like you're sitting there and
you have to be like you know
like i do i do vitamin ivs i i get of iv
of like a
super immune iv right that [__] is
intrusive as [__]
all right that needle hurts they have to
put this they put the sticky thing right
here
they rip my hair off every time they
take it i have to sit in this room for
45 minutes
i do that the the the the the
vaccine shot was like i don't even know
what he did
i was waiting and she was like okay
you're done i was like what you know but
it was sore though i mean it was my arm
was sore for days
but like it's not you know
anyways you know so i don't know man
like i i
i have a vaccine mark from when i was a
kid whatever the vaccine that
you know from what i don't even know
what it was for measles
yeah it's probably something like old
school yeah old school you know mumps or
measles or whatever it was
i mean i can see both sides if you're a
certain
demographic i can see why you wouldn't
want to take a vaccine maybe yeah yeah
i'm not i'm not i'm not making an
opinion either way about it i'm just
saying just be informed about it that's
all i'm saying
exactly and don't be mad if people don't
want you around
because of that yeah just don't yeah
yeah that's all almost turning into like
just politics yes it's too political
it's too politicized i don't want it to
be politicized i'm just saying
i'm just saying like if you like don't
be mad at a business that's like
hey you know we want to do this
yeah we want to go this way with it and
so we're saying thank you you can't come
uh you know what i mean like that's all
i'm saying that's valid
yeah you know what i mean like it's like
if we don't know like just get to know
know about it we all should you know
it's like i i just trusted the i
i was like okay i'll trust the science
but you know i don't even know if that
was an informed choice
like like you know i just said okay i'll
take the vaccine they're saying it works
but it's like i didn't know what was in
it i didn't know what was going on but i
just did it
you know and so it's like that's the
kind of thing so if you don't want to
take it you should be informed if you do
want to take it be informed
you know we're just not informed it's
just everything's [__] political
and everybody's got their everybody's
getting mad in the comments everybody's
got their
um you know dumb information you know
what i mean
yeah man clovid i know it's like
we never get it's like i feel like we're
never gonna get rid of it
you know i feel like we're never gonna
get rid of it listen i would think the
vaccine to be for money if they were
charging us to take it but they're not
even charging us you can get it for free
so i i don't even i don't even know what
what that part of it is either
so you know what i mean i i don't know
maybe the government's paying for it or
whoever's paying i don't even know who
pays for the damn thing
exactly but anyways just just let's just
get it
but don't be all i'm saying is my main
point i'm trying to make is don't be mad
if um
don't be mad if people don't want to do
it yeah
you know what i mean if people don't
want to if people don't want like if
they go like hey we want to have a show
that's fully vaccines because i think
they're just looking out for people's
safety
you know what i mean and liability i
mean it's it's it's two
two two phase thing man right yeah
somebody said the government pays yeah
somebody's paying for it right they
ain't doing this [__] for free
somebody's paying for yeah somebody's
paying for it um
somebody's making some money i agree
there's somebody out there is making
some money but
either way it's like just let's just
anyway let's move on from that
all right so what what uh nonsense you
got uh
uh oh you got a couple of things that
you always have to tell me about hey
have you seen this guy
this video is funny it's going viral
it's like this kid
uh who walked up to this dude with his
girl and was like hey you're really
beautiful or whatever and then
his boyfriend her boyfriend just sucks
on the face really
oh wow he was about it
i like how he wasn't just about he was
like let me put my drink down
[__] he's like shut up
that was you you know what i don't know
if you've ever been in a fight have you
ever been in a fist fight
uh let's see if i can pull up the one
clip of me fighting
oh you you been in a fight oh there's
nothing really um
but it was with my friend you know it's
funny like
back in the day that guy hit him like he
gave him up oh yeah he
mopped him he gave him a big hit right
yeah but it was like nothing
like in a movie that punch that dude
would have flew
yeah okay um
let's see here we go this is a
wiggy fight oh so you were in a fight
this is like
this is me and like one of my friends oh
this isn't even a real fight no i was
really pissed oh you were oh
you're really mad at him and your
friends were filming it you can tell so
this is like bum fights
i mean you can hear it i cracked him
pretty good
oh that was that was fake nah
almost look at he almost oh
you almost knocked him out are you
probably why you're a fat kid how old
were you i'm not
fat i was like
uh this is my shirt i'm not sad yeah
but um you look a little plump right
there i was like 14 or something
sophomores so what
what were dude i don't remember
um we we went through like lots of
phases me and that kid
fighting yeah but that was the only like
real fist but
actually he pulled up on me with a bb
gun we lived like a
we lived like what sort of white trash
neighborhood did you like
it it wasn't even white trash was pretty
nice but it was
just [__] well that did seem like a
really nice fight right there
yeah not too bad but this that kid
pulled up on me i told him to fight me
another time and
when we were like oh you're one of those
guys fight me bro he lived a blocker
he lived a block away and i was i mean i
was like a junior in high school and we
were both
super ignorant and like doing taking
[__]
god knows what but just uh off the shits
and so i was like yeah pull up and fight
me bro like pull up
and he pulls up in his car and i'm like
come on like get out of the car
and he rolls his window down and starts
shooting me with a bb gun and i was like
oh wow
what a [__] movie yeah so i like hid
behind the bush and i was like come out
and fight me [__] like
all this [__] but oh somebody should
have filmed that i know
but it was just me and him there so but
i'm not like much of a fighter really
uh okay would you punch a guy who uh
walked up to your girl like that um
i don't know if i'd snapped like that
yeah that was a lot check it out
let's get another song i don't know if
this one is even a good song
okay we got another super chat
from dan dayla
damn daylo thank you for that five
dollar super chat
super chat everybody in the chat getting
all
stupid about the vaccine let's just have
a friendly conversation that's all it
was
friendly conversation just be informed
that's all
don't be mad at other people just talk
new hunts yeah baby
[Music]
don't get me wrong
this guy over here some of these
comments are so stupid frankly i don't
even find
unvaccinated chicks attractive
this is just dumb man people get so dumb
people get so dumb and heated they get
so heated
all right well do anything else wigs
because it's just a bonus episode
we don't got to keep going we can stop
whenever we want um
let me i've been wanting to ask the
people this does anybody else
does anybody else's cats chew on the
corner like the corner of
uh their laptops oh yeah well first of
all just this [__] has
he's a cat lady no i got two cats yeah
okay
two and two is a cat ladies two
and you so you have four cats total all
right so that's okay that's cat lady
status but i only
live with two and take care of two oh
oh just two yeah who else got two cats
in the chat
nobody's got two catfishes yeah i know
people know there's nobody with two cats
in the chat right
your fans are all strictly non-cat
people
no they're just not crazy people that
have two cats okay nobody wants that
extra response but how do your roommates
even feel about that
we love them they they don't do anything
i mean they just take care of them they
just piss all over the place and [__]
all over the place and make them play
stink like cats
nah they don't even smell yeah i agree
with paul i'm also
super you know how clean i am cats are
yeah he's
not kidding every time he comes over
here he has to [__] about my desk
man i don't [__] but i tidy it up a
little bit yeah but
but he tidies it up with that kind of
attitude tidy up you know
no it's not it's not like he just tidies
up he's got tidy up like that
i do know
uh what else
don't oh dude don't say that kind of
stuff i used to i used to ran over cats
in my day
you're terrible come on not cool yeah he
deserves a timeout
what's that thing uh don't [__] with
cats
oh that's a great documentary have you
seen that never seen it oh
i think i started it god you have to
watch that
you have to watch that yeah i do need to
because it's like that one's just about
that just takes you down a rabbit hole
of serial killer type stuff man yeah
especially since i'm a crazy cat lady
right yeah yeah yeah you would be would
you be the kind of
are you the kind of person that when you
see an animal get messed up you kind of
like you know you
step up and say something well where are
you seeing where you see an animal get
messed up
no i'm saying it's like you if you're on
youtube or if you're like you know
somebody's talking about like you know
like i love watching those rescue dog
videos yeah yeah of course yeah yeah you
know so if you see performing animal
videos
i love yeah yeah yeah yeah so okay
that's what i'm saying so when you find
out about that i definitely have a soft
spot for you he's got a soft
spot for animals um okay what uh what
else
um that's it dude there's nothing else
have you watched pea valley
p valley know what's that one about it's
about like a strip club in mississippi
oh it's true it's actually it's super
well done it was really good
we just binged that whole thing finished
it rachel she's gonna hate me for this
but she just sent me a text message
she goes damn so farty today never
eating eggs before work
oh i thought she was talking about you
rachel apparently is just i thought she
was partying
about it yeah oh she does she just
figures she when i fart rachel looks at
me and goes
you make it so hard to love you
and there must be some wild farts though
but she also goes
but then she says later she goes you
know what but you can fart if you need
to because i don't want you to get a
stomachache
well that's at least just consider it
so she's very considerate but anyways
guys
um i guess we're that's it for today
this is just a bonus episode for the
week so when i have like a guest i'd
like to try to do a bonus episode do
more bonus episodes
i want to do some more patreon content i
keep saying this but we're going to do
it it's just
wigs we're going to do a music video for
my song one of these songs we should do
just
one of these for patreon too yes we
should do like a live
patreon but it's only like 13 people so
it's like
it's not like i have like if i get my
patreon up to like 50 people will do
like
live patreon episodes but
this has been great guys facts over cats
uh so anyways wait let me get one last
let me pick another song um
oh this is my favorite song
oh this one i call this one booty pop
song all right guys this has been
a bonus episode of
griffin thank you for being here
thank you for not spreading no fear
and everybody should cheer call it again
[Music]
i'm so stupid i'm not a rapper you could
be
but i'm a clapper and a zapper
a booty pepper the booty pop song and
you just gotta sway with it
sway with it sway with it
[Music]
all right shout out to everybody with
the super chats shout out to people on
patreon
shout out to uh even the no but whatever
i do for patreon i do for the youtube
members too so you guys are for youtube
members thank you i try to i'm trying to
put
the extra stuff up there for you guys
too so thanks for that shout out to my
cousin alyssa
for being here oh and jimmy knives jimmy
knives is my other wiggy
he uh does a lot of great videos for me
uh for the youtube channel so make sure
you check out eric griffin
gaming uh youtube channel so i got a
bunch of new videos up there and aaron
griffin gaming on
uh tic toc and then eric griffin on
instagram and remember i'm gonna be at
the brea improv
so make sure you guys check all that out
and i appreciate you watching
shout out to wigs for being here now
we're gonna go to dinner
and love you all thanks and peace
peace peace
just hit that right here it says